welcome to this video and this is the
start of a new thing opening week and
the theme for this week is the King side
here in shadow so I'm going to play with
a king-size fianchetto in all the games
and won one point of it is that black
has a hard time to prevent that or wide
for that matter so it is something that
can be done for both colors so we start
off with something that pretty much
looks like a reversed gruene felt an
interesting interesting thing to get so
I'm taking is d5 pawn if I go Knight c3
place 97 I guess huh okay or Bishop
before actually I could go we should
perform well okay didn't night c5 now is
this is this possible is this bonkers it
might be better to castle first but 95
is highly irritating ya know it is very
irritating actually where is he going
yeah it you can change 7 or you see what
can you go with this Queen and I just
take that and not be five well that's a
nice start for this for this fianchetto
week what a funny position to lack
resign oh wow one minute 30 that's cool
okay and I thought 1.e4 would lead to
quicker wins no it doesn't okay so let's
let's have a quick look here I will I
will do this review of all of the games
in the opening in detail in the in the
weekly summary of this this opening week
but let's just do that quickly this is
mostly just three the opening that cause
it was over so quickly f6 yeah an
ambitious way to play an interesting he
tries to play e5 if I don't go + d 4 now
he will have this in like here
and it's a bit of a Z mesh reversed
interesting move there might be a 4 in
this position because d4 maybe I have
this is this crazy then teresting check
probably not enough very weird position
but not sorry enough okay so d4 takes
take see five and now yeah hmm it's not
so easy to keep the center now yeah he's
not exactly strong and development he
only has played pawn moves this one and
ce4 also is interesting already that's
actually probably stronger how does he
play now I mean this 93 already is
almost sauce unbearable there and if he
takes I just teach a gig and again this
move huh okay so 93 it's stop bad
probably Bishop before is however okay
for him so c4 was much better actually
97 castles yeah and now nights if I've
looks strong I ok ok ok that's good
actually he he has to go here yeah of
course after I cannot really take as
this is attacking my night so this isn't
done that didn't really had such a huge
benefit but now everything's great i can
just take tier 9 p-5 is skilling yeah he
had to go probably here and then I'm
going back and I'm really ever born up
for nothing much but at least the game
continues a little bit ok I have fun a
quick win here for the first game of the
King fianchetto week thanks for watching